the Joe Rogan experience you know you
should go and watch if you haven't seen
it before watch again the hustler let's
say that Jackie Gleason and Paul Newman
I never said it's amazing it's amazing
for what reason it's just it's a [ __ ]
first of all it's it's in the 1960s like
early 1960s and you're seeing like this
part of America because this is filmed
representing the time in which it took
place it's not like they were doing a
period movie mm-hmm so this is like
1960s like early 1960s cars and the way
they talk and the way they drink and
it's about this guy's a professional
pool hustler who's been traveling from
California to New York City to meet this
guy the Minnesota Fats and plan because
this guy's the best pool player in the
world and so they play all through the
night yes pass on uh it was at Robert
Rosen is that the said Robert yeah it
said Robert Rosen yeah it's based on a
very you say Paul Newman is amiss yes
that's Paul Newman luck it is look at
that and Paul Newman plays Fast Eddie
Felson he plays the baddest [ __ ]
in pool it wants to come and play
Minnesota Fats Minnesota Fats is Jackie
this guy and he's amazing he's so
amazing he's got two flowers on his
jacket
bro that's a hankie rather had multiple
pool movies well this was the original
and so with the color of money with Tom
Cruise was was fast Eddie who was again
Paul Newman getting back into the world
of pool was the end of this movie
spoiler alerts from the 1960s retired
movie he retires he comes back to same
character okay yeah I've seen color
money but you know you're picking him up
again now and he's 60 that's hilarious
yeah this young kid is talking [ __ ] and
he doesn't understand that because he's
a really hot pool player today but he
doesn't understand that this guy in
front of him is a legend yeah the name
of his Billy was the Balabushka yeah
well exactly right yeah thank you that
he had and those because of this movie
this movie in particular that because
they didn't mention in the first movie
but it was pretty clear they were
playing with a Balabushka
this
movie that [ __ ] queue is worth a
shitload of money yeah like there's a
lot of like great pool to manufacturers
from that era like I know you like like
crafts I do totally in the world of pool
it's all about cues it's all about like
the the type of hit you want the type of
wood waiting and the yeah and Balabushka
have a very specific kind of hits a very
it's like there's an old-school feel to
it that a lot of the players that when
playing like most of life love companies
so around know if you're buying one now
you're playing it's gonna be a shitload
of money man so at this point it's an
art piece would you play with it if you
have some people do some people do it's
like a badge of honor you know you show
up at a pool hall with a bow but it's
not necessarily the best playing yeah
yeah it's like that's like got like
shotguns you know what I mean it gets me
the art pieces and the vintage II stuff
there's one right there for 20 mm on
that well let me see what that looks
like yeah that looks is that it oh it's
got the string on it it was the original
Cortland wrap and all that those inlays
that's pearl yeah that was all done by I
braid out in the bottom right no I don't
think so I think that's this there's a
type of that might be ivory actually if
it's old enough it's probably it might
be ivory it might be ivory you might be
right 22 geez they would use a plastic
down there because he wanted something
to be durable yeah on the ground or
whatever and they all used um ivory that
came from the the pre band days cuz back
then when they were making these things
people could go over there and shoot
elephants just for their tusks that's a
have any points mmm What's it saying
evany crazy gold bands racetrack mop
what is that
a nameplate okay racetrack mop nameplate
that's blank between I don't know you
lost me but think between the mop dots
and the diamonds original Cortland Matt
mostly falling off to original George
Balabushka shafts unusual that the
person dancing oh yeah well they've had
a bunch of those like that look people
would buy them they would order them and
who engraved their name and
yeah it sounds like a very shotgun like
thing shotguns are saying character from
the wood you have no you go over there
and you choose your wood and scrollwork
and the barrel work and all that crazy
she's a good friend of mine makes pool
cues is they're called sugar tree uh-huh
and his name's Eric Chris but he makes
them all by hand I'll show it to you
afterwards I'll let you sure you've got
like a dozen of them out here right it's
his his the way he makes things is like
super specific he's like ah he's an art
connoisseur if would was an art huh so
like when he looks at like a piece of
wood he he doesn't think it's like a
combination of knowing it'll make a good
pool cue but also wanted it to look a
specific but they have all these gnarly
knots in a beard kind of colors of the
woods and just finds which interesting
green check out
it's the just like gums yeah same thing
was a sex cool Balabushka pool cues were
reintroduced in the 1980s with their
permission yeah but that's not real yeah
once the movie came out someone asked if
their creations it yeah it's it's what
happened was there was a company this
it's a it's a decent queue but it's not
like you know though of reels like a
Shelby Cobra right you can buy a
wrestling Cobra but the real one even
like the way that one plays better I
mean there's people that like the way
all kinds of different things but it
might play better than there but it's
not you call it a Balabushka but how
bushes gotta make yeah he's got people
uh same thing cobras you know that you
could brand-new replicas Shelby Cobra
will probably drive a lot better than
the ones they were raised in the sixties
but one is 50 grand and one is a million
yeah as one is real and to be honest
that wouldn't mean I wouldn't buy a one
of those newer bowel Bush because either
if I wanted a Q to play with no they all
please you know what you're getting it's
well yeah yeah the thing with cues is
like with a lot of things it's like you
wouldn't if you see a pool cue like it
doesn't even necessarily have to be
anything fancy it's just you see like
the with if it's got nice wood and nice
balance to it and you can look at this
oh yeah you look at you know somebody's
made that by hand most likely something
I crafted that on a lathe and with
notches to you know
[Applause]